Grizzlies are playing with heavy hearts
tonight with their thoughts and their
minds back home in Memphis and with the
Memphis community and the family of
Tyree Nichols in fact just moments ago
there was a moment of silence here at
Target Center for Tyree Nichols and for
the Memphis Community the Grizzlies did
release a statement earlier today they
said we're distraught to find ourselves
dealing with a needless loss of life due
to police brutality and this time it was
one of memphis's own we're thinking of
the Nichols family and friends who share
the pain being felt throughout our
community so let's support each other
respect how our fellow Olympians are
coping we have faith in this city and
our power to heal to the Nichols family
and friends we offer our deepest
sympathies and condolences for your loss
hashtag Justice for Tyree the Minnesota
Timberwolves in the entire NBA family
are deeply saddened by the tragic
killing of Tyrique Nichols we extend our
thoughts and heartfelt sympathies to
Tyrese family friends loved ones the
Memphis community and communities across
the country during this difficult time
please join us in honoring the life and
memory of Tyree Nichols with the moment
of silence
thank you